yeah it's premeditated filled by when  you saw what he said about you with the  bed and the pillows but these [ __ ]  love hovering the whole [ __ ] bed all  the way to the edge of the bed to this  I didn't know that he was gonna air our  Dirty Laundry about our marriage being  so terrible  term yeah from the Rocks when I met  Steve and we first started dating he had  an air mattress with one pillow which  was sweat stained no sheets oh God  blanket that was a fleece blanket not  even a comforter he's a simple man still  [ __ ] him and I still came back so [ __ ]  you Steve you moved in with me [ __ ] and  then I moved in because he had it he got  it you got it you got it so you guys  were sleeping and [ __ ] on the bouncy  airplane try to see what it was like  because I never [ __ ] a guy on an air  mattress before I never slummed it that  hard and I upgraded this man's life and  this is thanks I get I still sleep on  the couch that's upgraded from the air  mattress don't don't brag